also meine frage ist warum nicht endlich
konsequenter gehandelt wird
es ist doch nun sehr offensichtlich dass
dieser lok downlight absolut nichts
bringt und trotzdem wird immer noch um
gefeiert und sich daher zurück gehalten
endlich konsequenter zu sein und viele
entscheidungen getroffen die wir die
jetzt geschlossen haben müssen um ihre
existenz bank einfach nicht
nachvollziehen können warum werden zum
beispiel immer noch unzählige leute ins
ausland geflogen während hier die hotels
dicht haben um ihre existenz bangen
verstehe ich nicht warum müssen betriebe
schließen die ein vernünftiges hygiene
konzept hatten sich auch daran gehalten
haben während in bussen und bahnen und
flugzeugen die leute immer noch dicht an
dicht sich drängeln und sitzen und
stehen und da überhaupt gar kein hygiene
konzept vorliegt wie sollen wir die
gerade um ihre existenz bangen das
verstehen
lieber einmal richtig als zehnmal
halbherzig und genau so läuft das aber
gerade halbherzig halbherzig gutes wort
also ich glaube wenn einmal zu völlig
recht dass wir viele bereiche haben in
denen ein facharzt ende nicht gehalten
werden können ist ein problem deshalb
schon infektionszahlen so hoch dass uns
zu behaupten dass es irgendwelche orte
gäbe horst ansteckung grundsätzlich
nicht stattfinden
das ist sicher nicht haltbar sondern
ansteckungen finden überall bestatter
abstände nicht eingehalten werden können
und alltags masten reduzieren das risiko
wo sie heben müssen auch natürlich nicht
augen deshalb ist die aufgabe die wir
jetzt haben genau das klarer zu sein und
deshalb da wo wir abstände noch
ermöglichen können abstände und da wo
wird es nicht können die anzahl der
kontakte reduzieren
das sind die zwei maßnahmen die sind
absolut notwendig und umgedreht muss man
denjenigen die jetzt auch zum teil
beschlossen haben dir sagen wir hatten
jene konzept wir haben momentan in
nahezu allen lebensbereichen hygiene
aber trotzdem war und hatten wir im
september schon und da sind die zahlen
im winter so exponentiell gestiegen
das heißt unsere hygiene konzepte waren
vielleicht ausreichend um uns durch den
sommer zu bringen aber sie waren sicher
nicht ausreichend um uns durch den
winter wobei viele wirte sagen jetzt
habt ihr die restaurants so gemacht die
bars zugemacht die kneipen zugemacht und
die zahl werden gar nicht besser zeigt
doch es lag nicht an den restaurants
bars und kneipen
doch die zahl dass wir haben ja mit dem
was wir beschlossen haben dieses von
diesen freizeitbereich haben wir doch
gesehen dass von einem exponentiellen
wachsen und mit einer verdopplung zeit
von sieben tagen wo wenn man mal weiter
gerechnet hätte auf dem höhepunkt anfang
november dann wären wir im dezember
jetzt in katastrophalen zuständen das
haben wir schon mal geschafft durch den
teil der maßnahmen die wir jetzt
ergriffen haben zu vermeiden das ist
eine ganze menge vom exponentiellen
wachstum zu einer seitwärtsbewegung aber
es ist eben genau nur der halbe weg und
was das wichtigste daran ist dass wir
auch nicht vergessen dürfen viele
ansteckungen finden im privatbereich
statt das heißt es geht auch nicht ohne
die bürger und deshalb ist das glaube
ich das schwierigste an dem was wir
gerade haben dass wir immer fragen was
hat der staat erlaubt und das genau
schöpfe ich aus oder wenn er nicht genau
hinguckt dann handle ich auch von einer
gewissen diese diese nikolaus feiern die
wir heute erlebt haben an verschiedenen
stellen
das macht mich echt sprachlos